good at me you didn't it how are some of
the best hugs in the bed I'll say it
come on man you are Jerrod Carmichael on
your dry Carmichael you are a hilarious
stand-up comedian thank you you're from
North Carolina North Carolina I get
differing opinions is calling North
Carolina North Cali
ah not in the early 90s it's all right
like well but I know that Google who is
person of like 95 that's all I ever
wanted you accomplished the way to a
good joke is paved with bad jokes
yeah right and sometimes is paved with
other great jokes and we call that an
act and we call that a career I remind
me you met with Bill Cosby yeah we both
love the cause Calvin I think you
remember I still record for myself the
going to tell the people that story tell
you went to his house yeah what's his
house yep and I heard heated leather
floors in the COS house no there were no
leather floors wood you must have been a
different way
wait what my friend yes went to his
house hmm
hand-stitched heated leather floor
here's the thing perhaps yeah I also
wouldn't put past him having like
hardwood that he had some button in the
floors flipped like so much meaner
because he has that kind of much like
venetian blinds yeah exactly
this is like a switch out floor where
every tires but on my way out I saw a
quarter because you know I don't really
take pictures and anything chair I saw a
quarter and I was like no we're gonna I
might I'm about to steal a quarter from
Cosby said I'm gonna still look at and I
stole a quarter and it's in my pocket
right you still have it I have it on you
take out the cards boy let's see the
cash corner yeah let's not cause I feel
you can't normally do this with some
1995 mint condition quarter this is your
cosmic where's my cosmic order here you
go it is it's like if it we wrote that
visions of our own death